tom holland bumped into a major
celebrity on set got pulled off by a kid
playing an extra and he flipped and
climbed his way through multiple movies
so how does he do it all
we've got all the behind the scenes
shots and a ton of commentary from the
cast and crew who make all the magic
happen so stick around for the good
stuff we're getting spidey
number one
tom's the bomb he's just the man for the
job all right so is there anything we
love more than this amazing duo not only
are they a great couple in real life
their chemistry and work together on
screen hits it out of the park and
what's even better is how much both of
them adore and respect each other's work
he's great he loves his job he just
knows his character so well that he just
can fall into it which is really cool to
watch after filming such stellar footage
it's no wonder these two wanted to spend
more time together off-screen he's a
really good dude and i think that that
really shines through on screen i mean
one of the most special parts of all
this is the fact that i got to meet tom
holland
number two
i'm the superhero i'm supposed to look
cool okay so they're a solid duo but
that height difference between these two
did prove to be a bit of an issue at
times on set i would land before him my
feet obviously hit the ground before he
does safety was of course a question and
pretty intense but of course the key to
all good relationships is working
together as a team and zendaya really
did tom a solid i would sort of land
like this and my feet would swing from
underneath me and then she would catch
me
number three burr need a scarf there
peter parker the set turned out to be a
total winter wonderland filming for
spider-man no way home it was chilly for
sure but that didn't stop holland from
bringing magic once again
number four
the chemistry between him and tom is
undeniable and hilarious
okay so we've got some great duos to
love in spider-man
of course we'll always ship mj and peter
parker but that bond between ned and
peter well that's one for the books tom
and i had really hit it off from my
first screen test and it's been really
easy since then the love between these
two seems endless and it made for some
fab performances on screen
betty
just give me a minute with my friend
peter just give me a minute with my
boyfriend whoa whoa hey look i
appreciate you bro
spider-man's best friend ned played by
my very real best friend jacob batalon
he's probably the most important
relationship throughout the movie he's
the only person who he can find in to
talk about being spider-man
number five
again i asked for a zip and i didn't get
one them spidey suits are tight we're
talking very inconvenient and oftentimes
awkward tight however the whole
headpiece area was pretty complex in how
it was put together
the eyes pop out and there used to be
these fans i remember them bragging
about they added in these fans that you
could click and it would supposedly cool
me down they worked once but how did
holland manage to consume anything
there's a hole underneath the eye socket
where we used to be able to feed a tube
down and i could drink without taking
the suit off it certainly looks uh well
hey whatever works
that's the truth
number six
black clock hardcore parkour
i'm right behind you
so when they decided to film this did
the team just ask how they could push
tom holland and make him look cooler
than he ever has before
tom on wires running across things
pretending to pole vault up onto the
iconic rialto bridge because that
definitely happened and there's this
really cool sequence in the film where i
run across these kind of poles that they
would maul the boats to and it basically
required me to be on a high line
just look at him go
number seven
want to know how to make a wicked
entrance he decided to enter the scene
by jumping on a trampoline and doing a
backflip and then landing right in front
of me tom is like a superhero that was
incredible yeah holland wasn't holding
back at all
number eight
i zoom back i slam into the wall
and then all i hear is the sfx guy go
sorry
yeah
this was a bit of a stunt gone wrong
i was sitting on the floor rigged to a
ratchet which is a machine where i will
zoom backwards and slam into a wall a
super casual day of work for tom
the sfx guy will also click a button
which will dump thousands of gallons of
water on me and you best believe they
didn't heat the water it was freezing
just when he thought it couldn't get any
worse
we had to do it a second time but it
looked great
number nine
obviously at that time all of the
villains in the film it was a huge
secret that they were in the film so
they would walk around set with these
cloaks on
marvel keeps a whole lot of details top
secret especially with casting but in
one case filming no way home even
holland was caught off guard i just sort
of bumped into this guy in a cloak and
was like watch out me
the cloaked guy none other than willem
dafoe
spiderman i wanted to do it very badly
number 10
you know the one we're talking about the
one that made zendaya make this face
100 foot swing which was awesome
you okay
oh yeah
yeah i'm okay never never doing that
again we don't blame you girl number 11.
that was scary
the first day of shooting
i remember um not being able to memorize
remember my line tom is obviously vital
to the movies but his presence turned
out to be extra special for jake
gyllenhaal when he was struggling on set
and i went up to tom hall and i was like
dude help me out he's like it's all good
just relax these two of course turned
out to be incredibly good pals after
working together and we have no doubt
holland's help made a big impact on
their relationship number 12.
we don't get just one holland and no way
home we get an even smaller holland as
well if you could believe it he's
telling me about this scene they need a
young person to play a burglar whose
spider-man's going to catch he's going
do you think harry would want to do it
i'm like bollocks to harry he's doing it
the set became a pretty beautiful family
affair but holland wanted to make sure
his little bro could put his money where
his mouth was after rousing tom for his
complaining so we're doing this scene
harry's upside down swinging back and
forward and bless him he's doing a
really good job
so far so good he's driving him that day
and he's like mate you can complain as
much as you are we saw the film the
other day and they've cut the scene
that's a tough break little holland
number 13.
one of the great things about homecoming
in this movie are the astounding cast
astounding and talented it's something
pretty special tom's spidey power is
probably most obvious when holland is
pulling off so many of his own stunts
but basically i sit in that car and a
stunt driver sits in that little cabin
and zips around these streets and while
i certainly do a fair share of web
swinging and wall crawling i definitely
don't do it alone all the wicked
performances and tricks are definitely a
collaborative effort but tom's skills
really bring a whole lot extra to the
table the fact that they trust me to to
make that suggestion and then to perform
it later is a real privilege
number 14.
one of the main reasons why i'm here is
because i was trained in gymnastics and
i use it every day pollen's gymnast
background totally helped in securing
his role and on the set it makes him
that much more impressive as he really
embodies the superhero there hasn't been
a day i don't think on this movie where
i haven't had to use some sort of
athletic ability it's not easy work but
if we know anything it's that tom is
dedicated holland gets plenty of
practice off camera as well
[Music]
number 15
with holland on set sure there was a ton
of intense work and impressive stunts
but there were also a whole lot of these
i'm a virgin
[Music]
i was trying so hard not just me he's
laughing no we got it i got this i got
this my scene partner is breaking can
you see my face no not at all so i can
smile yeah you can smile okay it's been
an honor you can't your whole body is
moving
maybe we don't shake hands just do this
thank you
he just ran out like a grandmother oh my
god
yeah like a grandmother like a
grandfather darling nice to meet you
[Laughter]
this i don't think the shot works
number 16
a major reason for holland's success is
just how much work and effort he puts
into his job brings so much thought to
the character and helps us work out
things on set all the time can you say
dedicated and thoughtful performance
it's obvious to all those that work with
him and it even comes across in just how
passionately he talks about the work i
really think we've benefited the movie
by having me in the suit do the stunts
and pull the suit off so you can see
that i did it
number 17
the hard work obviously started long
before filming even began
it like makes every part of your body
shake and it's awful it's a lot of fun
and it works but it really is the worst
thing i've ever done there was boxing
and more boxing
and more boxing but the prep to play
spider-man included some more
unconventional fitness techniques
it's like you wear this sort of like
black suit and they put these pads on
you and you basically do like a yoga
class while they electrocute you sorry
they what
yeah it's like muscle stimulation but
you work out while you use it no
surprise tom wasn't such a big fan it
sounds kind of nightmarish we'll stick
with the boxing thank you
number 18.
well pretty much everyone we know is a
fan of tom holland
one little extra on set had quite a
different reaction to the superhero's
presence we actually had a kid on set
the other day a little extra and he i
walk on set and he's like pulling his
mom's shirt and i go over to say hello
there goes tom kind as ever he
definitely had no idea this was coming
and as i go to give him a high five he's
like no i hate you he's like i don't
like you those seem like fighting words
but turns out there was a bit more
behind it i went to give him a high five
again he's like no i'm on team iron man
you're gonna regret that one day buddy
number 19
zendaya got to see up close just how
tough being on set could be for her
co-star and partner especially when the
set was unprotected and the paparazzi
could go full tilt it's difficult for
tom who has to be in the full spidey
suit it's not like he can be incognito
holland has a ton of pressure on him but
the fact is that even when he's feeling
overwhelmed by the press when he's on
saturn in character he's 100 there and
never lets that performance suffer
number 20
have a great take everybody a lot of
energy if at first you don't succeed try
try again or in this case if tom holland
doesn't think his performance is as good
as it could be it's back to the drawing
board zendaya got to see just how
rigorous a worker he is up close i
watched him do a fight scene all day
which is exhausting he'd do a move come
back to the monitors watch it and say i
can do that better even if everyone else
thought the work was solid holland
couldn't rest until the absolute best
footage was there he's committed to the
craft for sure but this dedication it's
beyond impressive the people that are
here is why we make these movies alright
so by now we're pretty positive we can
confirm that tom holland is actually a
real life superhero he certainly has all
the goods for it and with zendaya by his
side honestly what can't he do
what's your favorite tom holland moment
[Music]